Apple CEO Timothy cook is breaking his
silence in a new editorial in Bloomberg
Business Week where he is announcing he
is gay he writes while I have never
denied my sexuality I haven't publicly
acknowledged it either until now so let
me be clear I'm proud to be gay and I
consider being gay among the greatest
gifts God has given me joining me now
from Bloomberg Business Week their
editor Josh tringle why now Josh uh you
know he said that it's something he's
been thinking about for a while that
it's not precipitated by any event it's
not a reaction to anything um but he's
been very private and he's always felt
that his job is to guide Apple um at the
same time the way he told it to me he
walks into his office every day and
there are two photos one is of Martin
Luther King right one is of uh Robert F
Kennedy and that some days those are an
inspiration and other days they're a
challenge and Martin Luther King's quote
sticks with him which is that life's
most persistent and Urgent question is
what are you doing for others and over
the years it's it's notd at him that he
is in a position of power and
responsibility a position to influence
people and so he's had these conflicting
values of privacy and wanting to lead
and he ultimately decided that it is
more important for him to step out to
represent not only within the business
Community but within the world because
apple is a global company um and to say
to people I'm gay I'm proud um so it's
it's an important moment within this and
within the moment was the moment in
Alabama in recent days how was that a
catalyst to this announcement in
Bloomberg business I don't think it's a
catalyst I think what we've seen in his
time as CEO is that Apple has taken a
very decisive turn toward standing up
for equality standing up for certain
kinds of values including
transparency not always the most popular
decisions within the company um so these
values are consistent with the way he's
been leading the company um at the same
time this is a big stat uh in my not
only for Apple but for society and for
American Business for soety for American
Business look there has never been in my
uh searching a CEO who has voluntarily
stepped out as a Fortune 500 CEO and
said I'm gay and it's not just a CEO of
any company it's a CEO of the most
closely watched company in the world
here's a quote from this sa say look
forward in Bloomberg business week on
activism I don't consider myself an
activist I realize how much I've
benefited from the sacrifice of others
so if hearing that the chief executive
officer of Apple is gay can help some
one struggling that's all fine but the
ramifications internationally we have
seen in business sure and look I I think
um the fact that he's the CEO of Apple
makes this both easier and harder easier
in the sense that apple is a company
that has long valued creativity
Innovation equality it's been P part of
their corporate values and he did uh he
told me that he he spoke to the board
and the board gave him complete and
utter support full support um at the
same time Apple does business in a lot
of places
uh could be slightly complicated but I
think that you know one thing about
leading apple is a desire and desire for
their products tends to Trump Prejudice
um but the point of all this is I think
that it is news today it is big news but
uh his hope and I think all of our hope
is that at some point it doesn't become
news at all but in order you know we're
at a really interesting moment where uh
you know we've got marriage equality
legalized in a majority of States we
also have states that can evict you for
being gay that can discriminate you in
the work against you in the workpl for
being in Alabama yeah and so I think
each step each person who comes out and
drives our progress forward makes those
things less likely and less relevant
within this I was struck by the brevity
of the article it is sharp and it is
pointed was there a desire on the part
of Mr cook to write a longer essay no um
he was very clear on what he wanted and
and you know the the backstory on it is
is pretty simple as well he called and
asked if I could come out and we had a
conversation and he had a he had
something written and it was crisp and
clear and frankly uh I hope he's
available for more assignments going
forward he was very easy to work with on
this but he knew what he wanted to say
and you know at a certain point there's
not that much more uh that's necessary
your Sam grobart did that fabulous
article I'm going to say two years ago
on the new Apple how does this fit in
this announcement today how does it fit
in to the the new group leading app you
know I I actually don't think it's going
to be it's removed is it yeah I don't
think it's it's going to be very big
news within apple as he says in the
piece plenty of people at Apple know
that he's gay it's never been uh a big
deal it's never that no one's ever
treated him or he's never detected being
treated any differently so I think
within Apple there going to be a lot of
people who are proud of him who are
happy for him and who are you know by
about 9:05 going to get back to the work
that they have to do another quote from
this essay by Tim Cook from Bloomberg
business Creek I've made Apple my life's
work I continue to spend virtually all
of my a waking time focused on being the
best CEO that I can be part of social
progress is understanding that a person
is not defined only by one sexuality
race or gender I'm an engineer and Uncle
a nature lover a fitness nut a son of
the South a sports fanatic and many
other things I hope that people will
respect my desire to focus on the things
I'm best suited for and the work that
brings me uh Joy what will be the
ramifications this essay particularly
within the political dialogue as we go
to the elections um my guess is that
there'll be a lot of congratul
congratulatory phone calls headed to
copertino today that a lot of people
realize this is leadership it really is
I mean we've had a bunch of well I think
of John Brown at British Petroleum who
what he went through for decades yeah he
went through for decades But ultimately
he was sort of forced out of the closet
and nobody wants to be in that position
I think that um we're at a place where
Society is is genuinely leaning toward
uh equality and so it's a it's a door
that is already opening and can be
pushed on I think politically he'll be
receiving calls from Barack Obama from
the clintons uh and and that there are a
lot of people who will be rooting for
this story to be a positive thing and to
go away swiftly because truly we should
we should all be getting back to work
Josh thank you so much Josh trango with
Bloomberg business week uh an essay by
Tim Cook an exclusive for Bloomberg
business week uh Tim Cook announcing
that he is gay